Boom and we're live. How are you sir? Oh brother, I'm so blessed to be here man.
I want to salute you to work that you do and the fact that you will.
One hell of an artists, man, I'm telling you. Well thank you very much.
Coming to the stolen def comedy at strange times. Ooh,
we to swing from the political, the personal from the animal's own,
do the a division area. Just a beautiful thing to behold. My brother,
thank you from you. That is an honor.
I've been a huge fan of you for a long time.
So for you to say that to me means it means the world. Oh,
it's a deep thing and I can see your love. Richard Pryor, man.
I walk in Yo space and I'm just chatting formed by the guys, the spirit.
Desperate at his place, man. Yeah,
it's here prior here.
Then when you tell me you work with two great Richard Price,
my five weeks.
I followed him when I was a young comedian at the comedy store.
I went on right after him every night he performed. What was that like?
It was strange to be in a room with him because uh,
when I was a 14 year old boy,
my parents took me to see live at the sunsets trip and I could not believe that
anybody could be so funny just talking.
That was my first experience with stand up comedy.
Other than that I had seen like I'd seen people perform on the tonight show and
things on those lines. A lot of hope and so many of the other talent.
It was like ha ha ha, it was okay. You know what I mean?
But when you see Richard in concert in a movie theater,
I couldn't believe how funny it was. It didn't make sense.
I had seen funny movies before, like you know,
comedy movies that were made you laugh but nothing, nothing like that.
I'm like this guy's just talking. It changed my life.
That's what you can see the power of art and it's connected to freedom because
I've always viewed Richard prior as a free, as men, 20th century,
certainly free as black man along with Muhammad Ali.
He's free as black men of 20th century. He is so self determining.
Yeah. The choices that he makes has to do with his own sense of self.
He doesn't care what other people think. He doesn't.
Another looking for other people's approval, recognition.
He's going to be who he is and he pays a major cause for that.
Anytime you that free in a world of such a such unfreedom,
you're going to pay up major, major costs.
But he had spectacular honesty and he took,
I feel like what happened was Lenny bruise open the art form up and then Richard
Pryor took it to a new place. And that's in terms of the, the origins,
the real greats. That's exactly, but then George, oh yeah. Hello George Carlin.
Well,
he was the most prolific lord an hour special every year until he died.
Every year he did. Anyway, each one different than but all three, but at the,
but you are in that tradition. I was saying, man, when I saw you doing the, uh,
the dogs and cats
and getting inside their souls,
you know how profound that is still man, an artist. And
as a human being to do that, I said, oh my God.
And it reminded me of prior to that,
it's when I walk in and I see your connection, I say, Oh, be
hm. I'll be, I shouldn't be surprised. Well,
it was just being in the room with him was strange.
I just couldn't believe it was real. You know, I was in my twenties.
You in the 20s. He was in his,
he was at the end and the guy said he couldn't walk anymore.
They used to have to carry him to the stage and uh, but he performed,
sold out every night sitting in the chair. Yeah, I sat in the chair. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. But it was sold out every night. People couldn't believe,
I'm going to see, I don't believe there's tapes of it.
I don't believe anybody recorded it. If they did record it, nobody released it.
It was just, it was, this was in the 90s. And, um, this was again,
this was the end of his life. He just decided, you know,
he was dying and he's decided he'd go back to his, his love go. Wow,
you want to go back doing stand up
cause you got, you all got that picture. January 1st,
1963 brother prior,
my brothers just broke down all [inaudible] brother Jamie got it. Me,
I didn't even know when he got around 35 days.
Jay, he had a woman that he knew, he moved to Pittsburgh,
apparently was, he was about 22 years old. Uh,
that isn't their prior conviction. There it is. There's a mugshot. Wow.
So he had a friend of his,
which is a woman that was singing in clubs. Her father was a cop and,
and his autobiography,
he wrote that among other things that he or she paid him or she gave him money.
He admitted to beating her ass. So I beat her ass first.
Didn't think about hitting a woman. As much as I thought about my own survival,
that led him to being arrested, uh, sentenced to 90 days. He served 35 of them.
And had a $7 fine. He had a crazy life man. He grew up in a brothel.
Yeah. Right. Then Peoria. Yeah. Peoria and all that.
Now with the violence against any sisters wrong, but prior dove, him and man,
he uh, he was wild, free, cruel,
tender genius. Crazy wrong.
As he could be right as he can. He's a human being.
He's a complicated human being. I never met him before, but uh,
it's his spirit means the world to me.
Me as well. Well, I think every comic,
I've never met a single comic that doesn't think he's one of the most important
figures in the history of the art. Probably the most important.
It's like him and Lenny Bruce in my opinion, and then Kennison later,
but Kinnison for a much, much shorter time. Who would be the greatest female?
A comic artist, I think Roseanne Barr. Roseanne. Yeah.
Roseanne is profoundly talent. Yeah. No doubt about she,
she doesn't get the credit she deserves because she's legitimately mentally ill.
And that's one of the things I had on the podcast to highlight with literally
mentally,
she was hit by a car when she was 15 she knows she spent nine months in a mental
hospital. Yeah. She lost her ability to count.
She was very good at mathematics before that and then after the car accident,
the severe head injury changed her personality. Yeah. Same with Kinson.
Kennison is hit by a car when he was young as well and changed his personality
radically to head injuries, make people very impulsive,
very wild and impulsive, and oftentimes a slave to their own impulses.
And I think a Kinison was a big example of that as was Roseanne,
but Roseanne was the first really loud, brash,
almost male female comedian who could kill like a man. You know?
She was,
well, what about the down rivers and the, Oh yeah. Louis [inaudible].
I Love Monique. Monique gets to me. She, she,
she touches my soul every time she's on the stage.
Do you, have you ever seen Miss Pat? No. Ms Baths a monster.
She's a monster and she's had a crazy life.
She's been on this podcast a couple of times. Her life was insane. I mean,
she was selling crack when she was 14.
She had a baby when she was 14 or 13.
She was pregnant at 13 with a married man.
Had a couple of kids with him. Yeah, she's,
she and she is so funny.
She's so wild and funny.
Yeah. Something about the, it goes back to aristophanes's, you know,
it goes back to a, uh,
those early comics in the history of the west who were willing to tell the
truth,
especially as it related to the everyday experiences of ordinary people.
You know, the first play, those texts itself, you know,
the republic was grounded in an imitation of the comic writers who were the
first to really delve into everyday people's experiences.
Not the, well to do that was tragedy.
Tragedy only had to do with what the nobility and aristocracy,
but it was comedy that dwelled into the lives of everyday people that played old
texts, the whole form and shifted into the dialogue and make Socrates,
of course, the grant, the grant hero.
But it was aristophanes's at least in the west who initiated this with the
clouds and, and frogs and so on.
And it goes all the way through from Jonathan Swift to mark twain,
to Nathaniel West to, uh, uh,
own the brother Ishmael Reed. I mean,
these are the great American comic writers, Twain Wes,
read and see comic write as a different and the tragic ones of Dostoyevsky and
not that the cop Kafka's comic in his own deep way to the greatest. Of course,
the checkoff dough. Anton Chekhov, I know you check out checkoff, right? No. Oh,
brother, you,
you haven't fully lived and read some cement on check off all you read.
Three sisters, uncle volunteer.
You read the Cherry or any of the short stories he's had over 6,000 in it.
Short
Stories, the beats, frost and
[inaudible] into the, um, in,
in the ravine or even misery, man. The greatest one is called a student.
It's only two and a half pages. It's his favorite short story.
Or You read that tonight. Blow. You're not mine. You listen to it.
You read that tonight. Listen to look. Curtis may feel doesn't, hello?
Stephen Sondheim. Okay. Steven Sondheim. No more into the woods.
Curtis may feel I loved and I laws and then the student checkoff.
Oh man, you'd be ready for some serious, serious cognac
on your recommendation. Oh No, no.
Cause I know you use serious side intellectual to you do your homework.
But I'm just saying this in terms of just enhancing, you know, all of our lives,
I mean the comic writers,
the Comedians of various sorts be they on the stage or video on the page are Ra.
I think the vanguards of the species in a very deep way. You know,
because we as a species have to objectify our grief and our pain and our sadness
and our sorrow.
And it begins with moans and groans and you transfigured those moans and groans
first into song.
But song then moves into language and the language is not rational language or
philosophy and dialectic, but it's a language of stories,
especially the stories that are self critical. We laugh at ourselves,
not at others. We left with others rather than just at others.
So it's not that sudden glory that Hobbs talks about in regard to the comic.
When you're looking down and condescending, you see,
that's an ever Mr cratic conception of the comic.
You laughing at the ordinary people who are so dirty and filthy,
it's profoundly anti-democratic, right? As if you know well to do. Folk,
don't fart. Don't, don't, don't, don't,
don't do number one and number two and fall in and out of love and act a fool
and live lives of [inaudible] consistency, right?
But back when you get these democratic forms of the comic c,
that's you and Pryor and Roseanne and Monique and George Carlin and all of that.
That's free spirit though, brother. In most of our lives, you see,
we dealing with the whole history of a species of structures, of domination.
Oh, pressure. That's the history of the species for the most part.
And there's moments in which there's breakthroughs in which there's a freedom of
spirit, and then you have some institutionalization of that, which is democracy.
That's why democracies are so fragile and usually don't last that long because
it cuts so radically, radically against the sense of really wanting to be free.
I mean, those just skews, right? Most people really are afraid of freedom.
They want to defer to authority, they want to conform,
and when they're introduced to freedom and they really catch his whole,
they say, oh my God has tremendous cost to be paid,
but I liked that there's something about,
and they, they can hear it in the music, they can see it in your comic art,
the priors and others,
and it allows these little effects and consequences that people's lives to
really enrich their lives before they die.
Why do you think people are afraid of freedom? Well, it's courage. I mean,
there is no freedom without unbelievable, unprecedented,
unstoppable courage and courage.
It's not widely distributed in this pcs bay.
That's a very charitable way of looking at people. No, it's true, man.
Rather conformed and complacent. They're complicit too. As they cowardly,
they well adjusted in justice and wanting to smile and walk around as peacocks
rather than cut against the grain and have to bear witness and therefore end up
on the cross or like Socrates condemned on most of the great figures that we
know. And so it's more consequences for that now than ever. Oh yeah.
Cancel culture. That's exactly right.
Oh it's true. It's very, very true.
But I mean we live in a culture that's so corporatized,
commercialize marketized. Um, it's all about money, money, money, status,
status, status, and you lose any deep sense of honor character.
It's all about what appears to be the case.
It's a culture of superficial spectacle.
So it's all about image you see and images,
just some, a surface phenomenon.
Well, I can't recommend your book race matters enough.
And one of the reasons is because of your analysis of that, your, your,
your understanding of this,
the superficial aspect of the pursuit that so many people are locked into from
cradle to the grave and you just,
you encapsulated that so well.
And the way you worded it and the way you phrased it, it's, it's so,
it resonates so well and I, I,
I really admire this lifelong pursuit that you have for not just understanding
these things,
but explaining them in such a succinct way where it's absorbable.
Like that book, it's in the 25th anniversary.
I want to talk to you about it because that's the one I read.
And it's so strange when you read something that's so,
it's so current, even though it's 25 years old,
it rings true and does that sometimes,
does that feel few times where you, you,
you have the same issues for that.
You spoke on 25 years ago and there's very little change in those 25 years.
No.
Wonderful. Deep question. No Man.
And I appreciate the Times that you spent reading. Oh,
race matters. But no, it's never. Few towns don't man,
never a few towns because you have a conception of victory that is not messianic
or salvific. You're not trying to save people. You're not to be a messiah
that brings some kind of grand a gospel to people.
You simply trying to touch people's lives.
So when you enrich and enabled person's life,
the way in which you've talked about debt right there,
you already talking about the ways in which you were touched.
That means ever no futility at all.
And there's certainly not if you told them to go to the, uh,
the full condom t of it, it's all, all we can do, you know,
as human beings,
is to try to inspire one another and encourage one another and enable one
another and noble one another.
And that in and of itself was what the Great John Coltrane call a force for
good. How do I become based on a love supreme,
a force for good in a colon crew. World Love Supreme.
Absolutely. Absolutely. And love supreme is not loving the abstract,
right? It's a love of beauty in its concrete forms.
It's the love of goodness in his concrete forms.
It's a love of truth and it's concrete forms.
Now I'm a Christian Revolutionary Christians.
I got a love of God mediated through Palestinian Jew named Jesus.
But that's tied to a justice that comes at a prophetic Judaism, right?
And we know Judaism, Christianity, Islam, all of these religions from me, uh,
have no wholesale monopoly on how we understand the world because they all
emerged at various historical moments.
But when it comes to this love that allows us to persist in a world in which
cruelty and envy, contempt,
manipulation, this honesty and that shot through all of us.
So we're not finger pointing the name called, oh no. You know,
I called up brother Donald Trump a gangster over and over again. And I,
and I say that because there's a gangsta inside of me.
I got to reconquer concrete every day. So I know gangsters.
When I see one and gangsters, not a subjective expression,
it's an objective condition, but you grabbing a woman's part that's gangster.
You dig with somebody oil, another country that's gangster. You lies.
And these people have said that the America's garbage quit lying.
That's gangster.
They got a critique of America you did to in American car and the genuine
inauguration. You said all you're talking about,
the full sisters in Congress saying, well,
all evil Jews know Dan said, evil Jews,
they said evil doings of Israel.
Every nation state is dumped some evil things, right?
If there's a Palestinian state,
which I hoped areas they're going to do some evil things.
Every nation state has to be accountable. You is Upo, Opo,
Guatemala, Israel, trying and so forth and so on,
and every nation state has been associated with certain forms of barbarism.
We know that, but there's some good things, some wonderful things about Israel,
some wonderful things about Palestinians and formation, creating a state.
There's wonderful things about America. I mean,
a lot of people say even brother Trump to all, they hate America now.
They love American comics. They love American music.
You ask sister Talia, you asked us the Priestley, y'all love a reefer.
I've read the Franklin means the world to me. What about buried Jake?
Mary j means the world.
Mary J and Aretha are as American as Donald Trump.
Even more in some ways when they been here longer than people been there.
10 generations.
Donald Trump's grandfather just arrive his mother straight from Scotland,
precious Maryanne, 1930 she arrived, right? And so in that sense you say,
wait, wait a while. Look, quit, lie. And let's just be honest and candid.
Just like the comics. Let's just be honest and candid and recognize.
Cause what is the definition of comedy? It is first drama,
which is conflict,
emotionally felt and critically reflected upon.
But it's that conflict that's rooted than incongruity.
Things don't fit. So that's the possibility of hypocrisy,
right? And we know hypocrisy is the tribute of vice, the virtue,
so that there's standards and you fall short. So you can laugh at it.
Now when it's really deep comedy is talking about the human condition.
See, that's a deeper thing. I see.
That's where you get checkoff and Shakespeare and joys and the blues.
Because deep comedy is the recognition of limits and incongruities at the
highest levels of the mind, heart and soul. That's the different thing.
So you can start with comedy with a, you know, the clown who was,
who's walking around, slipping on bananas,
or the sophisticated professor who doesn't realize that he got a banana hanging
out the back of his pocket when he's electric with the students. They,
everybody laughing. He don't know what's going on. Well,
that's bodily based comedy, you know,
farts and bananas and so forth. And it's, it's important. Yes,
but high comedy is the highest levels of human dignity,
love thought music, mathematics,
metaphysics,
and then recognize all of those are incongruous.
They're broken, they're fractured.
There's dramatic conflict of incongruity at the highest levels of who we are as
a species. That's deep stuff that is deep. So,
oh Lord, Lord.
Then one of the most fundamental questions of Western civilization is how come
Socrates never cries and Jesus never laughs.
Ooh, that,
that's the question Thomas Moore was wrestling with in the tower of London
before he was executed in his dialogues on tribulation.
Socrates never shared the t. What does that mean?
The founder of philosophy in the modern West has a love of wisdom,
but he never loves people because it's impossible to love human beings and not
yet tears. Wow.
You go to your Mama's funeral and you're not shedding tears and you're committed
to the Socratic ideal of self mastery and self control.
You need to get off the crack pipe, get off,
show her the depths of your love for her through being outside of your self
mastery. The tears will flows, you said, and that's the other way.
It's like your daughter,
this precious thing that you got when we walk in for your daughter.
You see when she graduates,
you and your wife are going to have tears of joy that ain't demoed for self
mastery. That's not the moment to be so cratic. And so when Socrates is dying,
his wife walks in, Z is antipathy and she's crying. He said, get her out,
get her away and get him. I can't stand tears. So that's a problem.
That's the problem. See, I come from Blackfoot, we start with tears.
All the mess we had to come to terms with. You know what I mean,
cries and so forth. And he was scripted.
Begins with the cries of oppressed people too. Right?
But then Jesus never laughs. Ooh, I see. That's a deep one. That's a deep one.
That's GK Chesterton Cheston said,
Jesus turns over the tables of the money changes.
He does not conceal his rage. Crucial.
Jesus does weep. That's one of the most profound verses.
And in the Christian Bible,
Jesus wept unlike Socrates. Why did Jesus weep?
He went for Jerusalem. He went for Lazarus. He left web force friends.
But Jesus hides and conceals his mirth. That's what Chesterson says.
Is there any laughter in the Bible? Well, Isaac means laughter.
When you think of the joke of an older Sarah given birthed to a young person in
a older age and so forth.
But it's hard to catch Jesus laughing.
None of the synoptic up the gospels have Jesus laughing.
Some people thought they discerned the grin somewhere cause he turned wine in
the water. He probably had a little grant on that. A little sub grant.
Exactly, exactly. But, uh, uh,
but you can never get the full scale and variety of the human condition in any
one tradition. I think one of the, one of the
beauties of what you're saying here,
one of the beautiful things about what you're saying here is the complexity of
human beings.
And when you're dealing with the situation between these girls that call
themselves the squad and Donald Trump,
and you deal with these very simplistic things like these chance of sending her
back or lock her up, or they hate America, or you know, this,
this is simplifying things is,
is so attractive to some people and so attractive during political discourse,
right? Dude, during these,
these times when you're trying to rally up a campaign and get, get,
get the audience behind you, this is when these simplistic things resonate.
But as a human being, we know that things like, I don't use these,
I don't subscribe to this idea that human beings are good or bad.
I think there's either way. Yeah, I'm sure.
Look the way Donald Trump loves his family. I'm sure there's love in that guy.
I'm sure there is.
Oh, I mean he's, he's had some, you know,
relations to his mother and his brothers and sisters that would not ones have
sheer manipulation of domination is no doubt as a human being.
And it's important to keep track of his humanity.
But at the same time what happens is the dominant patterns of behavior.
This is what worries me about brother Trump's Besley,
the fact that he's hit of the American empire and headed the government.
You see that when you have dominant patterns of behavior that are completely on
accountable.
See for so long he's been able to get away with things with no accountability at
all. Yes, that's what makes him a kind of a Peter Pan.
Like figure. He's pretty tell he became president Xi powerful,
but he hadn't grown up. But even as president, he hasn't grown up.
People had thought that he would grow into the office now he just hasn't grown
up and you know, he's still Peter Pan
to manipulate the office position to change to be what he is.
And I think people love that.
There are certain people that that resonates with them.
They think that's so attractive. They love it. Well
they, I think they love it because it's expense that,
I mean the first thing that you know,
Trump was able to do was to expose the prepackage commodities that we call
politicians that he came across as somebody who was just himself.
Yes. You see, yes gangster that he is,
and he'd just tell the truth. Oh, I was a close friend of Hillary's.
I've been at the same weddings and so forth.
Cause that's how the elite circulate in American Empire.
But then when they discovered Lauren Boho,
he's now he's posing himself as some kind of oppositional figure.
And yet he tied the big money tied to big military. When he gets in,
he brings in the old school militarise people.
He's still dropping bombs on the nine countries that had been dropping bounce
for the last number of years.
Tax cuts sound exactly the same that Mitch and McConnell and others wanted.
We thought we had something different here. You see. And it has to do with the,
well, when Mr larger storage, we have to be honest about this, that see,
we live in both of very fragile and precious experiment in democracy and we live
in an empire that is experiencing profound decline,
decay and deterioration simultaneous. So you can
from the very beginning in days was really in some ways,
much more tied to gold and resources and land.
And so is really crucial.
Democratic experiment is predicated on the monstrous crime against indigenous
peoples that we've never come to terms with.
So you get a lot of neoliberal chatter about America's original Sullins slavery.
The lie,
the original sin was we had to decide whether we were going to coexist with
indigenous peoples or dominate them. And the decision was,
for the most part, genocidal effect in terms of domination.
So it's a settler colonial society, a colony of Britain, you see?
Then we enslaved the Africans who become the basis of our economy and the vast
majority of profits made were actually tied to slavery.
That's why so many of the presidents,
first presidents in America were slave holders and the chief justice of the
Supreme Court and slave holders and so forth.
That that doesn't mean that certain democratic practices were not being enacted,
but it was enacted for white brothers with property.
The white brothers who had no property, they couldn't vote at all. The women,
of course,
couldn't vote until 1920 so they had domestic households in which they had to
find some sense of fulfillment.
That's what history of Patriarchy and misogyny in part are connected.
And then tremendous efforts come to expanding it,
expanding it. And this is why even when brother Trump talks about socialism,
he doesn't realize the pledge of allegiance was written by Francis Bellamy who
was a socialist. The song American, the beautiful,
which is one of the most beautiful psaltery Charles Sing.
That song could take you to a different place. I mean,
he's seeing things we can't see and you know, he's blind. You know what I mean?
America, the beautiful Elizabeth Lee Bates Socialists,
professor Wellesley, who was our greatest poet, wog Whitman.
Pete ties to socialism, who was our greatest philosopher, John Dewey,
democratic socialists his whole life. Helen Keller Deaf,
mute blind, graduated Radcliffe,
socialists, Ryan, whole neighbor,
the greatest Christian thinker of the 20th century, democratic, socialist,
moral man in the moral society. Martin Luther King, Jr Democratic.
So Ella Baker,
Democrat Democratic Socialism is as American as Apple Pie,
but with the communists and the Communist threat and the Soviet Union and all of
its repression and vegemite tation and violation of liberties and killing of the
culottes and so forth. In the American mind,
socialism becomes associated with communism.
So you saw brother Lindsey the other day, ray. Yes, he looked like a cartoon.
His version of, of, of Joseph McCarthy. They're all Communis.
They're all communists. And you see what happens.
He is in a neo fascist discourse, his treating way around the world.
If you can define a community as pure and then characterize those on the outside
of the threatening as impure and didn't view yourself as those coming to the
rescue to preserve the purity. It can be based on race.
It can be based on religion, it can be based on politics,
preserved at purity.
We saw it in the fifties with the hysteria communists with what Smith Act.
They're deported or they take an a jail. I think the first,
the first city councilman from Harlem,
Benjamin Davis went to jail because he was a communist. You see,
because they were the NPO. They said,
now communism needs to be radically called into question in terms of its
dominating forms like the Soviet Union and China on the mile and so forth and so
on. But at the same time,
when you look at Carl Marx and his critique of capitalism, he,
this is prior to let it prior to styling, he says,
capitalism is tied to this obsession with profit that puts profit before people
and it will generate all adoptees in which there will be grotesque levels of
wealth inequality and the only way that porn working people will be able to gang
assets to any resources to do organizing and mobilizing.
Now you're going to accept that Mark's as insight. What? I'm in a Marxist.
He just telling the truth. Do you think that
socialism just hasn't been implemented correctly? Is that what you think?
Because like the, the argument has always been,
show me a socialist economy or socialist government that ever worked. Right?
Right.
But there's so many people that find the idea of socialism attractive because
it,
it combines this idea of a community with a nation and that we're all tied
together and we have,
we obviously have some socialist aspects to our civilization in terms of like
utilities and they look at the military.
We outsourced the military firefighters, police.
There has to be some kind of governmental control. But the,
the problem is this,
that if we have to view democratic socialism as a moment in the larger movement
of democracy, my dear brother Jeff [inaudible],
who's one of the great philosophers and thinkers of democracy,
calls them egalitarianism, freedom traditions,
and that simply a way of saying that if you look at the world through the Lens
of the masses of people who are poor and working people,
what are the conditions under which they can have security from domination?
What are the conditions under,
they can have dignity by holding forms of oppression at arms length.
And for me is not an ISM. You see, if capitalism,
visa, VI, feudalism can generate liberties and freedoms,
I'm forward and that's resize. Lee.
What the middleclass is did when they broke from feudalism in Europe or broke
from feudalism and other parts of the world, right?
You had to overthrow kings and Queens in the name of personal liberties,
but those personal liberties were confined too often to white brothers with
property and the white brothers would know property.
They either tried to hold onto their white and so they become like the white
brothers were property or they make moral choices and said,
I want to be a person of integrity.
I want to fight with the folk who are being excluded.
And this is one of the problems in talking about race and white supremacy in
America because you see,
we think too often than mono lithic categories.
There's never been a white supremacy without fighting against white supremacy.
And that includes white brothers and sisters.
There's a tradition from hand Braden from miles Horton.
You have Highlander center, you've got that wonderful picture of Rosa parks.
She was at Highlander center four months before she was arrested,
before she sat down on a bus in order to stand up for justice right there at
Highland, the sun on the miles Horton, who was miles Horton,
a white brother who brought black folk and white folk together went to union
seminary, trained under Ryan whole Neba.
He had cousins in the Ku Klux Klan. Wow.
So his Thanksgiving dentists were very complicated,
but that's true for a whole lot of white brothers who fight against white
supremacy.
And Brayden a rabbi Abraham Joshua Hep test show me Edward Zooey.
You have a whole tradition of white brothers,
sisters who've been fighting against white supremacy. You get it in the music.
Beck's about her back.
He sitting at the feet of Louis Armstrong and he's a great artist.
Louis is genius of geniuses, right? And that middle-class brother from Iowa,
you asked him about why supremacy you as Brubeck about white supremacy.
You ask any of the appall Desmo,
all of these folk who are connected to traditions in which black humanity,
Brown humanity is seen and affirmed.
You have it. I had a
point in the book race matters.
It resonated with me that I never really thought of before.
And what you said was that because of the fact that the United States has this
deep history of slavery and the slavery of African Americans,
that white people became white people instead of Polish and German and Italian
instead of it being like most other countries where they,
they Italians think of themselves as the Italians and the Greeks are the Greeks.
Those were white people. They're all
co, they combine as white people. I never thought about that before. No.
What it means, you've got these scholars of American studies.
Let me nail painters, one of the tiring ones,
but it goes all the way back to brother Alexander and David,
David Roediger and some others who've been talking about
the way in which whiteness was created. Take for example,
an IRS brother who calls dot Ellis Island.
His people been dealing with 800 years of vicious British colonialism and
imperialism vicious to tax,
various famines that in some ways created or at least enabled and so on.
They get to New York and they're told that they are whiteness and no,
no because we know the British are white and we not British at all,
but then this is, yes, you are. Look at brother West. Look at Jamar.
Look at Latitia. Where are you going to go on the Jim Crow bus?
Just get off the boat from Ireland. If you go to the front,
you would vanilla folk. You go to the back,
you with the chocolate folk what you're going to do and for our presses,
Jewish brothers and sisters, it was even more complicated, more complicated.
They get there and they say, no,
we not with the goal and we're not with the gentiles.
Y'all been oppressing us for 2000 years.
Pogroms ghettos, holocaust,
vicious attacks and so on. But then they get there and say,
well are we going to be in the back with the black folk?
Some of them did you see, cause you got a rich tradition of progressive Jews.
Noam Chomsky would've got back there.
Stanley Aronowitz would've got back there with the black folk. He said, I mean,
but you got some other Jewish folk like any other group.
Well we kind of look warm. Let's just kind of move back and forth.
And then some of them want to assimilate completely,
especially the highbrow German Jews.
We're actually white as well as the jug towels. You're in America now,
get beyond that old world
prejudice. You say,
well you better check yourself because every Christian civilization we know is
shot through with Jewish Atrius. Mm. Don't, don't believe the hype.
Sooner or later it's going to be manifest. You see what I mean?
And so in that way you can see the discourse of whiteness, blackness, brownness,
redness and so forth becomes so,
so deeply rooted in American law, American structures,
American perceptions.
And this is why the arts are so crucial because it's primarily in the music and
in the arts where the breakdown of white supremacy begins to take place in the
country. It's not the politicians. It really isn't. It really isn't.
There's no accident that the first massive form of entertainment in the United
States is what the menstruals and black face. And you say, well,
what was going on with black where Eric Lot and others have talked about the
love and theft. On the one hand,
there's a fear of black freedom cause black freedom somehow means less freedom
for, there's
a fear of black creativity. Cause that means maybe white supremacy is alive.
Maybe they're human just like us. Maybe they just as creative, imaginative,
intelligent, just like us. Then they hit music and they say food.
They got something going on in the black side of town, but we don't know.
It was like you go to see prior, right? If somebody had told you,
oh brother Joe White Supremacy, America tells you that black creativity,
black intelligence, black genius doesn't exist.
And you go see pride with your parents and you go away thinking just negroes
with juniors. Somebody lied to me. I got to recognize that.
And then you recognize those,
the whole tradition of prior and we can go on and off from the cold train.
Sarah [inaudible] and on and on and on. Right.
And so people begin to think federally, white brothers and sisters,
my parents had been lying to us when it comes to black intelligence,
imagination and genius and humanity.
And yet the structures make it difficult for us to come together.
We're talking about up until 1960 that's a long time though.
1776 that 1964 and five that's a long time for both slavery and Neal slavery to
be in place and here we are now 54 years later trying to create a multiracial
democracy, which is a beautiful, beautiful thing.
And it's already been enacted in the and jazz groups slash stones,
bands, multi-racial. The comedies,
the studying of the calm is that you all have, you sit down with comics,
y'all talk about the genius across race and gene, junior,
gene and gender as if it's a natural thing that already shatters the white
supremacists and the nets in male supremacists categories, whiteness, blackness,
all in different silos. But it's so hard to do it on the ground. See,
part of the problem of talking about race in American as well.
I've been very critical of a number of contemporary black intellectuals because
white supremacy cuts so deep in the culture,
people begin to think it has magical powers and somehow it just floats above
American history as if it's just part of our DNA and not biological way.
But all conceptions of race in the modern world are grounded in predatory
capitalism so that the talk about whiteness and blackness becomes a way of
rationalizing social structures like slavery and Jim Crow.
And it has to do with trying to extract labor resources.
It's an attack on their humanity and identity,
but it's tied to economic structure.
So to talk only about race means we hide and conceal the social structures that
are generating unbelievable suffering for everybody.
Everybody you see. And so the last thing
you want is talk about race. I'd say the same thing about gender. In a way,
gender is much more complicated because gender has been around for so, so long.
Every culture that we know almost,
but in modern conceptions of race are tied to modern conceptions of predatory
capitalism here and abroad, which includes imperialism between clues.
Empires such as the United States comes out of the British empire.
We engage in a heroic,
courageous revolt against the British empire.
It was a magnificent struggle.
That's what I like about George Washington and Thomas Jefferson.
Cause I'm an anti-imperialist. They were anti-imperialist. They urban gorillas,
they picking up guns. They fight. I don't go that far,
but they're also white supremacists. You see,
so as soon as they overthrow or push back the British empire,
what do you get in the declaration of independence?
Beautiful words about equality, but you also get savages.
We got to take their land and you get an empire of liberty.
This is the where the comics come in.
What does an empire of liberty looked like?
Who's not in on the liberty is a whole lot of people not in on it.
Carlin, right? Carlin had this bit about,
this country was founded by slave owners who wanted to be free. That's right.
And Doug, but the American dream, you got to be, yeah,
you got to be dreaming to believe it. Can you sleep?
Do you think that much like this country is an experiment and self democracy,
a very recent experiment when you look at human history, right? Absolutely.
Hundreds of thousands of years that we've been human.
There's really only been a couple of years, a hundred years of this.
Do you think that that's maybe the lens that we should look at something like
democratic socialism through, not that it can't work,
but that it hasn't been implemented correctly before.
That's exactly right. That's why we've got to get beyond the ISM.
You're absolutely right. See what makes, uh,
not just United States has been democratic experiments all around the world and
various circumstances.
We become central stage because we become a world power that understands itself
as a democracy with all the contradictions that go ahead and an end with that
began as a settler. Colonial enterprise steel got slavery.
Patriarchy workers don't have the right to engage in collective bargaining.
United States until the 1930s Argentina had it in the 1830 Darden.
The teen is not known to being on the cutting edge for social justice love.
You're down there in Argentina, but they know that.
But they had collective bargaining. Why?
Because our Robert Barron's and our power elites was so powerful.
You See Rockefeller and company had private militias that were bigger than a lot
of public armies to make sure workers were not able to engage in collective
bargain. I was in San Francisco just yesterday at the Commonwealth Club,
which is now lodged the Longshoreman's association,
which is fascinated Commonwealth as well to do ruling class Harry Bridges,
Longshoreman,
Strong Union, Jack London and other great socialists there in Oakland. Right,
and what are they trying to do there?
We're just trying to ensure that ordinary people gang assets to jobs with a
living wage.
DCE and education is the one reason why I spend so much time with my dear
brother Bernie Sanders, right?
Because it's a democratic project that simply say is how come poor children
can't have assets to some of the things that the children have the wealth to do
have. They have the same value. And of course there was a Christian for me,
they have exactly the same value. So how will they get it? Well,
here comes socialist movements that say first they didn't want to do is we're
against child labor laws. That's, that's the jungle. That's up to Saint Claire.
He's a socialist. Tried to be governor of California. Right?
And what were they doing? What were these capitalists doing?
They're hiding these kids at six years old, seven years old,
they were dying at 30 there were no laws against child labor and working seven
days a week. So the labor movement brought us the weekend.
And I'm not talking about the singer from Canada, God bless him.
I'm talking about the two days we have off.
Because if we didn't have that from the socialist moving in, the labor movement,
they had been working young kids seven days. They did that year after year,
decade after decade. That's greed, right? And that's, that's greed.
There's no accountabilities z.
That's where that whole idea of the let the market decide falls apart because
the market just wants profit. Right? Absolutely.
And that doesn't mean that markets can not be used in democratic ways,
but they need to be ethical, but they got to be ethical.
You got to have some accountability and regulation of child labor laws were very
important that of a breakthroughs at that time of there other you had,
you need to have laws to make sure that the water was clean and the food was
regulated and clean and so there's a narrative that you get from poor people
often or people that are lower middle class that are against the concept of
socialism because they equate it with people that want a free ride, that trade.
They acquainted with people that don't want to work hard. That trend. That's a,
it's a strange narrative when you consider all the things that we talked about
already,
like the what we need with the fire department and the police department and all
the different ways that socialism does form utilities and all the different ways
that socialism does form that part of our culture and our community.
Why do you think that that is this narrative and how,
how does that narrative get reshaped? Because that narrative of that,
the only reason why people want socialism is because they want a free ride.
Right? Right. Oh, that's a wonderful question.
But the one is that you had,
first we have to listen very closely to a right wing brothers and sisters and
conservatives and Midler's because often times they're
human means like anybody else. And they've had their own arguments.
I don't think they have strong ones, but they have their own arguments.
So the first thing you'd say about that is what makes you think that the well to
do don't have free rides?
What is inheriting wealth all about? Oh,
inheriting wealth is free wraps a little is all it is. What is freak?
The connections.
So getting into the prep schools and the Ivy League schools and so forth,
even though they work, it's still a kind of free ride.
So if they're preoccupied with this issue of being free ride, we tell them,
let's make sure that people do work hard and sacrifice and therefore in some way
deserve what they have. Now, if just based on that principle,
the upper echelons of American society would be indicted,
deeply indicted. And it's not a matter of hating the rich cause.
I don't believe in hating anybody individually. I hate greed. I hate injustice.
I hate white supremacy. I hate anti-Jewish, prejudice.
I hate anti Palestinian prejudice. I hate patriarchy and so forth.
But the human beings,
what these ideologies filter through are still human beings.
You see what I mean? So that's the beginning of it. Now, of course,
part of the question here is has to do with a, they'll say, well,
we wasted this money on the pool war. You said, well, wait a minute.
Donald Trump just passed a $750 billion military budget.
Democrats voted for it too. How much waste is in the military?
Why is 60 cent of every $1 coming out of the federal bullet budget tied to the
military?
Why is it no close oversight and accountability of it?
How come American people don't know about the four countries that we're bombing
or assisting other countries in bombing? And we can go right down Pakistan,
Afghanistan, Yam and absolutely Mali,
Nigeria, Somalia, Iraq.
I mean you can go on and on and on. Right?
How can we don't know about the 4,800 military units? 587 around the world.
We've got US special operations in 128 countries.
Only under 97 in the world. Right. What about the soldiers who die?
Hardly any talk about it. What about the innocent people?
We kill hardly any talk about it.
What about the drones that we still dropping and not always on military
combatant,
but in the sent people to h o sometimes even disproportionately.
Those are precious people too.
It may have the same value as anybody in Ethiopia, America,
Chicago. Feel the don'ts.
Drones are particularly insidious because it doesn't even seem like it's really
happening
because it's a robot doing it. Absolutely. It's done. Lonely distance,
remote lead, no human sensitivity at all.
Apparently the PTSD that suffered by those remote drone operators is pretty
profound too. You could understand that. Yes, deeply
and yet no serious public conversation about it. In [inaudible] day.
I was on the plane the other day and uh, the pilot says, ah,
I hope you all are able to take a few minutes of your time because we've got a
family outside waiting for the body of someone just killed in Afghanistan and
Italian family in Chicago.
One of the saddest things you want to see in your life, man,
as a family lined up and they bring in the body out and you say to yourself,
how come there's no public spotlight on that?
And you see what I was growing up in the 60s, Walter Cronkite and Vietnam,
we saw the bodies,
well during the Bush administration,
they made it illegal to take photographs of flag draped coffins.
It's exactly, which is unbelievably insane.
That's exactly right. And continued under Obama and company, you know,
and you say, well, wait a minute, a day. Their pen is ultimate cost.
And the, uh, the change, the narrative and the tears of the, the families.
And he can't even put a public spotlight on it. God.
And then of course they lie to us as well.
Our drones are not in any way killing civilians and they end up killing an
American and they have a press conference that same day in economic
compensation, the family, the rest of their life. I agree with that,
but what about the drones that are killing folk in Yemen and Somalia and
Pakistan and Afghanistan? Oh,
they denied or even killing them and you say, quit lying.
That's John Brennan and company using both Bush and Obama administration.
You see, how do we keep track of those in the name of what?
Democratic accountability. That's not socialism.
Socialism is democratic accountability,
but there's been socialism without democratic accountability and what do you
get? Tyranny. That's Soviet Union and company,
but when you get capitalism with no democratic accountability, what do you get?
You get a predatory capitalism with gross wealth inequality and everyday people,
the masses of poor and working people fighting for crumbs
and there's also this denial of it amongst the most patriotic,
they don't want to consider it.
They don't want to factor it in to what we think of when we think of America.
The great you don't you want, you don't want to factor in those innocent people,
which I, what was the last time we checked? It was in the 90% right.
Of people that are, that are killed by drones are actually innocent.
It's some insane number,
but we have to have voices. That's part of the problem though.
You have to have voices that say,
I don't give a damn for popularity.
I'm trying to be wedded to integrity.
I want to put a smile on my grandmama's face in the grave and she told me as a
Christian that if the Kingdom of God is within you,
then everywhere you go,
you ought to leave a little heaven behind and heaven takes the form of laying
bare the humanity of each and every one of us,
especially the least of these as the 25th chapter of Matthew, right.
What you do to the least of these you do unto me, who are the least of these?
The orphan, the widow, the poor, the children, the elderly,
the workers, the gays and lesbians. The trans, especially the Trans these days,
they just trashed like, I don't know what, but the black folk,
they're brown folk, they're white, poor,
they're indigenous peoples, not just here but around the world.
And what does that mean? That means that you have a, um,
a certain kind of calling that will always pit you over against those who are
well adjusted to injustice, no matter what color they are.
Well adjusted to injustice as just very, very beautiful way of putting it.
No, it's, that's, that's part of the suit part. Part of the problem,
the American dream. It doesn't go far enough. The American American dream says,
I'm gonna work hard sacrifice and get mine and live large and some vanilla
suburb, maybe with a trophy spouse. I feel good about my shot.
You say nothing wrong with wanting to gain access to resources.
Nothing wrong with working hard and nothing wrong with living where you want to
live. But then the question becomes, now you're successful but you're not great.
Greatness has to do what he or she who uses their success for something bigger
than them, service to others.
Service to the least of these so that the great ones like the Richard Pryor's,
you see not a matter of how much money he may as a matter of his soul in his
comedy and the love that he left in his legacy,
Martin Luther King Jr died basically a broke man gave every penny that he won
from the Nobel prize to the movement. Malcolm x,
the only one that had $150 in his pocket.
Who cares about the richest black person in 1968 and 1965 that's ephemeral.
We talked about deep joy, deep love.
We will remember those who raised their voices and said in the name of something
bigger than my ego, when my narcissism and my hedonism and we all have it.
We all have. So you know, we have to always be self critical in that regard.
We all fall short.
You know the Great Samuel Beckett and I'm a great now the great comic writer.
Try again. Fail again, fail better. That's the story of our life. Try again.
Fail again, fail better. But even in failing better,
we can at least raise our voices and try to connect the two movements and
organizations and structures and thank God we still do have a,
a a significant number of decent people in the American impart it.
Just feel powerless.
Well, there's this conversation that's happening now, right,
and this is a conversation that's based on the information of recognizing the
fact that so many people have wasted deep aspects of their lives, long,
long lives pursuing meaningless things and and recognizing that there is a lot
of injustice in this world and that people are,
are afraid of admitting that injustice because then they would somehow or
another be complicit in the enactment of that injustice.
I think that's one of the things that people are terrified of.
When you talk about doing something to reinvigorate poor and disenfranchised
communities, they start talking about the welfare state or what it's,
this is not how things should be done and people need to pull themselves up by
their bootstraps not recognizing that everybody isn't starting at the same
starting line. Absolutely.
There's a concept that I've been talking about that if you really cared about
America, you would want less losers. Like what was the best way?
What's the best way to love America? What would you want more winners?
You'd want everybody to be a winner.
Like if we have these disenfranchised parts of this country that have been that
way forever.
There's a guy that's been on this podcast who was a police officer in Baltimore
standards, Michael Wood. And uh, he, uh,
talked about how when he was a police officer,
he recognized the systemic racism and how, how crippling it was.
And one of the things that he recognized was they found a piece of paper that
was a blotter report of all the different,
various crimes that were committed from the 1970s. It was a, a,
some year in 1970.
It was the exact same crimes in the exact same communities that he was dealing
with them. And he was generation after just recognizing the red lining,
about the fact that there was areas where black people were not allowed to buy
homes, that they kept them in these communities,
the same crimes kept occurring in the same places and all they were doing was
going in there and arresting people and nothing changed and nothing was fixed.
And as a police officer,
he was realizing and just becoming aware of the fact that this is,
he's a part of this system. He didn't want to be a part of the system anymore,
but he was a part of this system that is creating this problem.
When you address that though,
the people that don't suffer in those communities that aren't a part of that
community, there's a natural inclination to resist. Oh, that's true.
And it's because they don't want to do anything. They don't,
they don't want to think they're responsible.
They don't want to think they're a part of it. They don't want to discuss it.
Even discussing it. You feel resistance.
They will in the state of denial, yes. Trying to avoid and trying to evade. No,
it's, it's very, that's very real. That's very real. But you know,
it also works, uh,
within communities of people of color. And this is again,
why I think we have to resist any monolithic care or homogeneous
characterizations. People
B see so that anytime you talk about white supremacy,
you've got the John Brown and you know Mary Ellen pleasant,
who was the a black woman who was worth $347 million in the 1840s.
Whoa. She's called the mother of human rights in California. She do.
She made a rich white brother and he died on her.
So she ended up with man's of dolls. Worst thing she did,
she gave John Brown $1 million. Wow.
John Brown had even noticed from her in his pocket when he was at Harper's
ferry. That's how he survive. You see now, John Brown was killing some people.
I think that's wrong. I don't believe in innocent people no matter who they are,
no matter what color. But at the same time,
John Brown had a love of black people,
much deeper than many black people have with themselves because he's willing to
die for black people. But the same is true within, let's say, black communities.
You've got, okay, 1% of the population in America alone, 41% of the wealth.
You've got three individuals who have wealth equivalent to 160 million fellow
citizens. But within the black community,
the top 1% of black folk have what was 70% of the well.
So that means you got a lot of pressures Jamal's and Latitia is out there who
don't are,
who are told to live vicariously through the lives of black celebrities.
So it's all about representation rather than substantive transformation.
You get that in politicians, you know, you got a black president,
all y'all must be free. Isn't that a beautiful thing? Live through him,
live through the family, beautiful achievement, magnificent achievement.
But it's not about symbolic representation only.
This is about fundamental transformation. So it's a challenge. Mary Ellen,
pleasant and others and Martin King and others up challenges.
For those of us who do have some resources to still raise our voices because you
can be black highly well adjusted to injustice economically in terms of race and
so forth. And the same is true. You can be Brown, you can be real.
So it's not just a matter of looking for that one individual who represents,
it's a matter of connecting that representation to fundamental transformation.
If there's no fundamental transformation,
you end up with a whole generation of peacocks. Look at me, look at me,
look at me all about for legend. What does that do?
That falls directly into the culture of superficial spectacle.
Wasting we need is just spectacle with no substance in that way.
And this is a battle within a,
within the communities of peoples of color because it's not,
it's not going to be a matter of just pointing out why supremacy because white
supremacy is fundamental foundation and part of the country is not the only
foundation cause you got resistance to white supremacy. Yeah.
Lydia Maria Child,
she wrote a book in 1834 call an appeal for that class of Americans called
Africans who was deeply influenced by one of the greatest works ever written at
that time by David Walker appealed to colored citizens of the world.
She's a white sister.
She is as vanilla as Doris Day and the 1830s fundamental part of the black
freedom movement. Right?
We see those folk need to be lifted up because what does that do?
That exposes our humanity in terms of the choices we make,
not just the skin color we have,
and I would say the same thing in terms of gender.
The brothers who are fundamentally concerned about breaking the back of
patriarchy,
even we know patriarch is shot through us because we grew up in the 1950s and
sixties no man escapes it, but you try to reconquer it all in the same as true.
Where are precious gays and lesbians and Trans Folk?
You see the to be decent human beings who make moral choices. He,
I believe in the primacy of the moral and the spiritual,
the centrality of the artistic, especially the musical.
And especially the comics as the Vanguard's who represent a freedom and a
courage and a vision to connect us as human beings because you can't really be a
comic with a wholesale Nazi ideology.
Now you can be a Nazi genius like Martin Heidegger,
who was a great philosopher and a genius and a thug when it come to pop when it
comes to politics. You see,
but a comic has got to be able to be open enough to deal with the incongruity
and inconsistency and the sheer absurdity of it all
about moments of freedom earlier.
And I recognize that as like one of the greatest things you ever see when
someone's on stage and they're killing those moments where everyone's together,
they're all together, locked up in the laughter,
and they're all to get that there.
This a sense of community that you share with the people that are in the room.
Perhaps it does bring people together,
even if it's for brief moments for a few seconds,
or what songs it takes are not to be trashed.
Life consist of moments. Yes. You know what I mean? Yes,
definitely.
And See, it's in a democracy. You see,
it's those moments that constitute the memory of what could be as opposed to
what's in place. You know, the Great August Wilson though, the great playwright,
black playwright, deeply influence, he said by
the Blues Berakah and beard and Roman beard and a great painter.
But my Mary Barack, of course from Newark like yourself,
there's like Sarah Vaughan and Phillip Ralf by different newer,
he used to say that performance
authorizes alternative realities for the audience that gets them to unsettle
their perceptions of the world. Whoa.
And that's what great artists and great comic, but deaths with debts with Jews.
Yeah. That's your do strange times though, bro, that,
that you bring in the fact that we're living in such a grim moment,
what I'd call, you know,
an American empire in decline and we all need to call for his regeneration is
democratic revitalization and regeneration.
But how do we do that only by example, man,
because there's a difference between the, what the Great Roberto Hunger Calls,
um, by a graphical time and historical time.
All of us are born in circumstances, not of our own choosing.
We're only here for so long. We all have insecurities, anxieties, and fears.
Knowing that our bodies will undergo extinction one day very soon.
And therefore to deal with those insecurities and fears and anxieties,
you have to have certain structures of feeling and value that give you some
sense of worthwhileness as you've moved through time from mother's womb to tomb.
Right?
And it's only in biographical tag cause we only got one life decided to Jordan
and there's no person who was a messiah. Nowadays,
people will tell you they are, but you say, okay, just go with it.
Be Self deceived and drink your cognac and keep moving because there is no
messiah is out there. There's no saviors out there.
There's no messiahs and groups. There's no messiahs and collectivities.
There's only lives to be live. We back to check off again,
lives to be lived,
acknowledging things were in place before we arrived.
So therefore we ought to have gratitude for the love that we received.
That's how I begin my my whole life. I am who I am because somebody loved me,
his mom, his dad. That's my brothers and my sisters,
my friends, right? And I don't deserve it.
And I have to somehow following Ashford wins, Ashford and Simpson, and they say,
send it like a puff of smoke. You got to let it go. Spread whatever.
Love, justice by example.
Examples are the gold card of Justin. That's a wonderful line. In consequence,
[inaudible] pure reason. Examples are the gold card of judgment.
The judgments we make a predicated on the examples that we have,
and we must have examples of greatness.
If you're gonna be a classical composer,
you better studied some loot v Beethoven.
You're going to be a serious artist of musical theater.
You better study a genius who's still alive named Stephen Sondheim from west
side story,
the company to Sunday in the park with George to passion Sweeney Todd across the
board. Not to imitate, but just to know what greatness is in your genre view.
In hip hop.
You better study some rock him who you better study some followed the leader who
loves put Tupac, Dad's ride. You studied the folk
with grades the same way. You know, you study prior and Bruce,
Lenny Bruce and the others, and Roseanne Barr and the others.
But that's one of the more important parts of being a person, right,
is to really your diet of what you take in,
in terms of whatever, whether it's your art or whether it's your education,
try to take in the best and most inspirational and the most spectacular versions
of human human endeavors. Absolute. See,
that's one of the reasons why sports is a kind of American religion. Sure.
Because in sports or whatever,
I know that you got the the taekwondo thing. Yeah. Yeah.
And you understand the role of excellence with the Greek Scott or Tafe take that
place,
but to be able just to turn on our television and see by the Lebron James did
his thing.
That's another context that cuts across race, class, gender,
and so forth. Let Broan how you do it.
Didn't memories of Mike Jordan and [inaudible] important.
I leave when he sat out those three years and then the late 1960s because he
wouldn't go to Vietnam. Courage. My mom, Muhammad Ali,
along with Richard Pryor Richards,
it was the freest Black Black Man of 20th century. Uh,
but see the boxing is so crucial as well as the, uh, the, uh,
the other sports because for black people,
every other sphere in the society is unfair and unfree.
But when you get in that ring and the referee is fair,
you finally get fair competition. That's what Jack Johnson was such a threat.
Remember when Jack Johnson knocking white brothers out,
there would be racial riots against black folk killing black folk all across the
country.
Don't you get the idea that just because he beat the white man in a context of
fairness that you can beat anybody?
And that goes all the way to Mohammed Ali. It's very interesting.
And the time I spent with another genius named Prince who we'd missed so, so,
so very much this, nobody like him,
but he like Miles Davis View Jack Johnson as his favorite black man.
And that interesting, well, he was a pioneer because there was none before him.
Jack Johnson was Jack generally the first, Oh, by him, by himself in many ways.
There was one I think, but not as famous,
not as famous in terms of the spotlight. There was other great boxers that time,
but he, but he just took it to heighten. Yeah, leave the country and so forth.
See and what Muhammad Ali, you know,
you got someone who was just himself in the context of a social movement that
was taking place at the same time.
So he would associate himself with the black freedom movement called the civil
rights movement. He joined the nation of Islam under honorable Elijah Muhammad.
They became then became very close to Malcolm x and had to deal with the split
in its own way and ultimately becomes, you know, a more Muslim.
But at the same time recognizes his political consciousness was tied to the
nation of Islam and so forth. And for him to do that,
I mean to be associated with the honorable Elijah Muhammad,
the nation of Islam probably had about 0.1% approval in the country and probably
about four or 5% in the black community because at that time black folk and
Black Christians were just afraid of the black Muslims.
But it was Malcolm x who in his,
all of his genius made it so broadly conceived that even Christians like myself,
I'm a f Jesus, love and free black man,
but I can't live my life without Malcolm c and he's Muslim to the core.
He's praying five times a day. You know what I mean?
That's just the beginning of it. And he's also very complicated too,
because his grandfather was white. Well, he had been first white.
His father was a Garveyite is his mother, was tied to the interracial,
but her father was [inaudible] who was killed. His mother, of course,
put in the US in the sane asylum. He's a foster child.
The great stories he tells in the autobiography of Malcolm X,
one of the great classics. Really,
I mean more than history of American civilization,
but very misunderstood in terms of the cultural narrative of who he was.
Absolutely. No, it's true. He used to say sincerity.
It's my only credential. Ooh, isn't that powerful.
Damn sincerity.
So when he said White Men and women are devils,
and he believed it, now he's wrong. No white brothers, sisters, not Dells.
Then he says, I changed my mind. They're not devils.
They too many got devilish behavior. He dry.
Cause that's true too many of all of us have dealt his behavior.
But when he said the first thing he said what he meant, he meant what he said.
When he said the second thing he said what he meant. He meant what you said.
How many folk do we have like that today that aren't scared to change their mind
and speak with deep enough soul ditches up? See,
one of the great gifts of the artists,
and I speak about this especially in the black tradition,
is what we could call soulful Kenosis.
K. E. N. O. S. I. S.
Now kenosis means self-giving self donating and self empty.
So if you go to a James Brown concert,
that brother goals for four and a half hours and gills,
every thing, every fiber of his be Yang. And at the end of every concert,
what does he say? I'm an extension of you. You're an extension of me.
I don't exist without you.
Did we fail to play a song that somebody came to hear and a sister holiday.
You didn't play soul power and he say hit it boots.
Say I got to play that song
because he's serving. You see Al Green, you go to Al Green Concert.
That brother came walk after the cancer.
He's given everything from false settled at, tended to everything. Ultimately,
that's what happened with prince, right? I mean prince had such incredible,
his hair was hip jumping off piano. That's on jump off.
That's how we got hooked on pain pills. That's exactly,
and that's what killed him. Ultimately,
John Cold train blowing his horn as if his neck is going to snap every night.
Then he gave a concert in November,
1967 66 right before he died in July 67 he drops the horn,
start beating on his chest. Man, I shit at least say what's happening trade.
He said,
I'm just giving the people all of that Canon now my board getting in the way.
Oh Wow. You know what I mean?
But don't you feel that when you walk off the stage, man,
when you walk off the stage of strange times, man,
you giving everything all that Joe is at that moment.
Now what is that you see?
That is the example of a love supreme that is there to serve the people.
Now you're going to make a living too. They're going to get paid,
you're going to get paid and so forth. But that's not the primary thing.
That's not it seem. Curtis Mayfield sings,
sings his songs that the radio won't play when he's told not to go to the
rallies and he shows up with his guitar anyway in plays we a winner.
That's self giving, self emptying.
And I tell it to the young musicians these days,
cause a lot of you know in the culture of spectacle nowadays, shoot,
you get these performers,
they just show up and think they ought to get a standing ovation for 10 minutes.
Say No Negro sang a song first man, shit
ain't no spectacle. And Peacock,
we want you saying something that's going to stir all souls the way Sam Cook and
John and Taylor and Lou Rawls when the soul stirrers did. It's not,
we respect that genius and so forth, so it'd be yawned.
Say it's fascinating this regard because she's a genius.
There's no doubt about it. She's,
I think she's the greatest entertainer of our day.
I've been very critical of her because there's a sense in which she's still tied
to the cultural, superficial spectacle,
jumped the way she looks and girls in formation and so forth.
But at the same time she was also grounded in the tradition and this new movie
that she made. You see that? No homecoming. Now I'm saying, Oh man,
you got to see, that's one of the greatest performance of films ever made man.
When she goes,
she goes to Coachella and she shows her Coachella with all of the bands of black
colleges and performs all of her songs with all of them moving hundred and 5,200
of them. Wow. And then reflections and Nina Simone and a brief of Franklin.
I no, Beyonce. See I was wrong about Beyonce in a certain sense.
Now I'm telling you that sister,
she brings a tradition with her that the highest
level of both respect and of excellent.
Well maybe she changed who she is because of criticism like yours. Well,
you just saw, you have never met her, you know, so for sure to say it's,
it really is hard to say. People hear things like that.
It does make them think that. I think that that could be the case. I mean,
she married to a genius for sure with Jay z too,
and of course the kids and her lovely parents and family and things.
You never know what goes on in the mind and heart and soul level.
A great artists like Beyonce. When was it that led you to be critical?
Initially? Oh, just because up. I'm very concerned by young folk.
I've made three, three smoking word albums with prince singing with prince.
He was up, he would not sample any of 'em,
allow any of his music to be sampled by hip hop artists.
He was very hard on hip hop. But when we asked him for spoken word,
he said yes and thank God we did same as true for the greatest soul singers,
generation,
Gerald lavert who really deserves so much more attention a WHO's on the album
and so forth. So I spent a lot of time with young folk in studios,
just did a thing with tough pole and one of the great artists coming out of a
Ferguson and American Empire on Black Julian to uh,
e 40 of 'em coming out of Layo. I have great respect for, uh,
I've been blessed to do a number of things with the young folk, but I tell them,
I say, I'm old school Yo, you need to know that. See we into originals,
not in the copies.
You see that we into lifting every voice that's so full so that we stir souls.
We don't want to just titillate bodies.
We don't want just stimulation of body edges. Now,
I'm not a puritan, so you know, I believe in body stimulation at the right time.
You know what I mean? They ain't got nothing against orgasm. But the thing is,
you know, you can't just orgiastic Lee moved to life.
You've got to have context. You got to have tradition,
you got to stir souls in that way and so I put a lot of pressure on him.
One of the things that I bring a lot of critique the barriers. See,
I am deeply shaped by the dramatics, the Delfonics,
the main ingredients to whispers, lakeside,
James Brown's band, George Clinton, Bootsy, his band.
I'm shaped by the emotions. I'm shaped by the Jones girls, the miracles,
the temptations, Marvelettes,
all those were groups that expressed their soul full self emptying in a form of
sweetness. I believe in sweetness
and with losing that, I go to the young folk,
where is your dramatics?
Why is it we don't have large numbers of groups that sing in tune with a beauty
and a sweetness and a gentleness and a kindness.
When you hit a voice of David, referencing ain't too proud to beg.
The vulnerability, the flexibility of it,
the intensity of
it in it goes straight to,
so that's why the people keep listening to David reference from why not
Mississippi?
I would say the same with Ted meals of blue magic that I get the young folk just
to stop. Let's just listen to Ted meals at a blue magic.
Let's just listen to Russell Thompkins jr the stylistic, oh,
brother West, you just old school.
You just nostalgic now love sweetness, gentleness.
Never go. Hasta as my brother would put a clip, never go out of style.
Everybody needs sweetness, kindness, gentleness.
Black music used to be the fundamental conveyor of that sweetness.
So did the bean Crosby's, the Frank Sinatra's. These are great,
great geniuses themselves. You have frank, who are you inspired by?
Billy holiday. Oh, you talking about the genius from Baltimore City, Billy.
That's trap. You are Italian working class brother from Hoboken. That's right,
because I'm tied to excellence and sweetness. Now Franks is not true.
He is saying some sweet, gentle songs now. Yeah,
but the younger generation these days, they've got John Hayman,
some mothers who can, who are beautiful, don't get me wrong,
but it's smaller and smaller,
but it's partly a matter of the oligarchs in the recording industry.
[inaudible] boys, the men in a way,
as the last great group singing a performative act that connected to the
dramatics and Delfonics that I'm talking about. He said, well, what happens?
While they think they could make more money with just one negro,
with a microphone run in their mouth, that you get a genius,
like Kanye deeply confused politically. We won't go into that.
All this Trump connection. We need some serious push in on that brother.
But they'd rather have an individual isolated,
easier to control in the industry.
And the same oligarchs run live performance radio and the music and the
products.
You know how they've now undergone this fundamental transformation and industry,
especially given the new technology and social media. So I tell the young folk,
I say, you know,
I could not have grown up without the sweetness of those rhythm and blues
groups. Now I know the circumstances are different,
but where do you get your sweetness from musically?
What will be the soundtrack of your freedom movement? Genius.
It's like Kendrick Lamar providing some of the soundtracks.
There's no doubt about that. And then there's others as well, but not enough.
Not enough soul stirring that it is. No. Curtis may feel nobody.
Nia refund, nobody near smoky, right connected to the peacocking.
Oh Lord Jeff Social. Yes. Loot image. The combs,
tiny Instagram pushed buttons. The Bentley's, Oh,
we've got to be in front of the commodity and so forth and so on. Hey,
jewelry. I made feet up in the grass. He had his sharp cars.
But when that genius got into the studio with the same love TK, oh,
you don't give a damn what kind of car he got. I don't touch his soul.
You know what I mean? And it's not just on the black side. We've got, we,
you know, you got a vanilla blues,
men like Bruce Springsteen and the Jewish brothers genius up yelling from
Minnesota, Robert Zimmerman.
All of these folk were involved in the KENOSIS activity of self empty,
but they were deeply shaped by the sun houses,
the Robert Johnson muddy water.
The Morena is the best hit Smith, the blues tradition.
Do you know Gary Clark Jr Gary Clark, Jr. I've heard that name,
but I had missed that. I gotta check him out. You.
I need some education. My brother,
he, he is one of those rare musicians where you hear,
hear a riff and it's a Gary Clark Jr pull up that pull up that video of when he
played with my friend Susanne from honey honey, and he,
they did a midnight rider from the almond brothers,
but he did it as Gary Clark Jr. He's got a sound of his guitar.
It really reminds me of Hendricks in a way. It's very different than Hendricks,
but it reminds me in that it's so distinctively him. Oh, I got to hear this.
Yeah, he'll pull it up right now. Thank you so much.
He's a brilliant guy and a great guy too, but he's a,
he's just a unique, unique artists. Like,
I don't know anyone like him and his sound. It's,
it's one of those things where there's no,
there's no mistaking who's playing the music when you hear him. Oh,
just sit in the chair. Then when he's playing midnight rider,
which is a classic. So many pick classic song. Yeah. Put, put this up,
give it put up. This is, this is them up there. There's Gary.
Oh, here's Gary a guitar. This is me filming this. Is that right?
Yeah. It was in the crowd. They did this midnight on a Tuesday in downtown La.
How long ago was it year ago or so? Just recently? Yeah.
This motherfucker.
Oh,
here's what
my favorite artists per shot and hit that Robert Johnson and him already.
He's got everything in there. That's also buddy guy, buddy guy.
Once you hear more Gary Clark, you realize this is him. This is him. I hear you.
You could feel it in the air in that club. It was maybe, well in
that club, Suzanne is reading the lyrics from her phone. She didn't even
know the lyrics. They did this totally impromptu. It's bad on the spot.
Totally on the spot. Totally on the spot. Unprepared. They talked about, I said,
let's do midnight rider. Okay, we'll go here. So they had, they weren't even,
they didn't rehearse this. They didn't at all. This is his takes off on it,
like just takes off on it. Just did his version of it. Austin, Texas. Oh,
here from Deli light. Then Hopkins. He's a complete motherfucker. Wow.
He's a bad motherfucker. Check him. He's,
he's one of those guys that you watch him and you could just get a tangle like
he's like, there's an energy that comes out of him. Undeniable greatness.
That's part of that self. Yes. Yes. Domain,
but he's also an incredibly humble guy. No peacocking at all. He's not,
he's an artist.
A sign of spiritual maturity and moral security is secured.
It makes you want to pick up. Yes. Yes. He's just devoted to the work.
Devoted to the art. How is he not Gary?
He's probably in his thirties he's very young. Yeah, he's,
he's still getting better. Who's his latest shit as his best shit?
He lives here in La as it goes back and forth.
The Teddy's around here all the time. 35 yeah. I don't know.
He think he's out here now, right? Isn't he out here? He was just,
Suzanne just sent me a text message.
They were just jamming in his house last week, so he must be out here. Hey,
he's got some shows here in September.
I think he's opening for the rolling stones. Oh Shit. Oh Shit.
Caught up. That's a hell of a show right there. Ooh, yeah, he's busy.
He's, there's a sign poster him over by the kitchen.
Something for me. Yeah.
You got to get somebody to come out to check him out.
I'll tell you which one to get. It's a, he's got some great, great work,
but there's, there's those artists that when you hear their thing,
whatever it is, it literally gives you energy. Like you feel it in your body.
It's like a drug. It changes your state. Absolutely. No, I mean,
when w w when you have the very,
um,
creative marriage of technique and vision of craft and imagination mediated
through sound,
the vibration that I'll say, ah,
just beyond the link. But you know,
the great John Coltrane had a whole philosophy of vibrations.
Sun Rowe was part of that dialogue as well.
Eric Dolphy some of the role geniuses of that time, you know,
and these vibrations are just,
they're as real as a heart attack, but you can never see them.
It's almost, yeah.
Joel was bootlegged to find the materialist as someone who was obsessed with
utensils and afraid of perfume,
because for fume, you can't touch it, but it's as real as a heart attack. Yeah.
Well, the vibrations of deep music,
Mozart to the miles or Mary Lou Williams,
Jerry Allen, or any of the great artists, it just goes through you. Yes,
and it's not simply cerebro. It doesn't bypass the brain,
but it doesn't stay in the brain. It goes through your whole body. Yeah.
It's like you said, it's like a drug. Got It.
It changes your state. Yeah.
If there was a drug that you could take that made you feel the way you feel when
a great song comes on, you would want to take that all the time. All the time.
Yeah. If it had no side effects, well,
in a way you can play that song over and over. You can. I mean,
eventually you get a little bit tolerant of it, unfortunately,
but who would have major musicians that were shaping your sensibility?
I was always in the rock and roll.
I was always in the classic rock when I was young. You know,
I was always into God from everyone from Queen.
I was a big queen fan when I was a kid.
Definitely don't get into Boston yet. Well I left New Jersey when I was seven.
Oh No, seven no, this was boss.
I lived in San Francisco from seven to 11 that I lived in Florida from 11 to 13
and then Boston from 13 to 24 so he was mainly that Boston context where you had
the classic rock. Yeah, a lot of Aerosmith, which was a Boston Ben, of course,
you know a lot of Van Halen. Oh yeah, yeah.
There's a lot of that.
I didn't get into classic rock as much as I probably should have.
It's only so much time. Yeah. This is only so much time to listen to music.
That is an issue, right?
There's so much great work and every year new great work gets created check of
Oh love. Because it was mainly rhythm and blues on our side of town.
You know what I mean? Yeah. The Sacramento, California jazz came later.
And then for me, musical theater came.
It didn't classical music cause I played classical violin 20 years. Yeah.
Oh Wow. And so a classical music was always van pulled to absorb.
A lot of times you learn hip hop, man. I was first filing
man. I used to conduct two oh man on a clown and knock music with Mozart.
We play Eg mountain but Beethoven and so forth. And as soon as it was,
oh, I'd go home and you know, Rockwood odors, red man and uh,
and when Isaac k's at black moves and great Barry white and others.
But it's fascinating how you begin to see these connections to broader
connections. And so classic rock was something that I got to real late,
but late as in, you know, 2122 and in that sense, um,
and very much so, but uh, a world without music
that would suck. Well it's interesting too when you,
it's all about the context of when the music was created too.
Because if you go and listen to Robert Johnson today,
it's still undeniably brilliant.
But what's interesting is it was so good back then that people thought he sold
his soul devil. I mean, that was the narrative. That's it. That was the legend.
But if you to it today
in comparison to something like Gary Clark, it's so simplistic. It's so true.
It's true. If Gary car could go back in time to when Robert Johnson was alive,
they would think he was from another planet. But that's the truth.
They wouldn't even understand it.
They wouldn't even understand what he was doing.
That's very real. Now,
I used to say I was blessed to have dialogue with the BB king on a number of
occasions is the ability, the king in a lot of ways, king,
not because he was the greatest blues artists,
but because he was a great blues artists.
Through his personality and through his generosity was able to create such a
presence that he becomes the king in that way. I had a chance to see him live.
You saw him laugh us. He sucked. It.
Was that at the very end when he was sitting most of the time, no,
he was still standing. Still standing. Okay. Late nights. Oh yeah, no, no,
you absolutely. The power out of his voice. Amazing.
But he used to say that, uh,
the blues was a kind of high school visa,
vi the jazz who are those who went to college and by college he meant just
studying with bird. But Armstrong with Duke, with uh, rough,
the foot in the Mary Lou Williams and the others. And I always tell him, I said,
I don't know about that because you know,
the genius and excellence comes a number of different forms.
Most jazz musicians don't have the genius of a Robert Johnson.
And yet, you know,
Charlie Christian's guitar is more complicated in a variety of different ways in
rapid Johnson too.
So that you had to be able to be flexible enough to see the differences that
development building on the genius of those who came before.
So you can end up being a very good guitar player who plays some unbelievable
court that Jimmy Hendrix created. Yes.
But you build it on Jimmy and it becomes almost not taken for granted,
but something you can use as a launching pad like Stevie Ray Vaughan did. Yes,
he wrote the great jammies vibration.
That's a great example of his own feel to it. Absolutely. Absolutely.
And here again, you see, you have the um,
that common humanity that cuts across color and there's a lot of controversy
these days about cultural appropriation. You know,
can white brothers and sisters really, uh,
be part of a black genre and so forth and so on.
I had a dialogue at my class at Harvard this spring.
I teach a course on black intellectual tradition and I include some white
intellectuals as part of it. It was a strange career of Jim Crow for example,
by the great event, Woodward, a history of Jim Crow to the Bible.
Martin Luther King said, was a Bible of civil rights movement.
Woodward was a white southern brother and I, and I asked them, they said,
we don't understand completely by the West. I said, well, let me ask you this.
Is Eminem a part of the hip hop tradition at the highest level?
Yes, he is. Yes, he is. That's who we told him about. Hmm. Let me see.
You had to be a fool to deny the genius of m if m and m d c
But relative, there's no way my name went out, Dr Dre and so forth.
So he immerses and soaks himself in it,
but he puts his own distinctive stamp on it.
Calling oaks would be another righteous brothers,
another average white band from Scotland. Definitely.
You know what average white band and the funk that David generate. Oh my God.
Now of course, no average white band without James Brown. James Brown.
I took her to places nobody took. But you let those guys,
brothers plague person to person on you.
Oh Lord have mercy. Pick up the [inaudible]
pieces. A Y mad.
You had to go a little high and you have to go and make me learn you in a slow
magic. I mean it's just so full man. You say Scotland,
Scotland, Robert Burns, Walter Scott,
David Hugh colonized by the British empire responding in their own creative ways
in by the 20th century. They soaked in rhythm and blues too.
Korea is like that today. Really? Oh Man.
You Know Caribbean pop, k, pop and K. Rhythm and blind. No,
they've got a lot of break dancers over there. Oh, it was not just bts.
Not Bts is something else. They pack Madison Square down,
but I'm talking about like Urban's urban [inaudible] May.
Oh they you put on coffee man. Oh Lord have mercy.
I played at the Dan Danny Glover the other day on the Bernie Sanders campaign.
We traveled way off in the country in South Carolina for brother Bernie.
I say Dan, even Sam Francisco. I said, man,
listen to these young Korean brothers, man,
they can remind you the natural for Richmond. And I put it on,
Oh man, there could can be Korea. What you talking about?
Sure. That was, Korea's got a soulful sound man at a blow.
Yo Mine, I'm just reading the book called the birth of the book Korean. Cool.
Was this the wall? Oh Wow.
And it shows again how you know that human spirit is always grounded in
something local and particular light black music. Right? But it travels.
It's the roots and the routes.
So the roots of black, but the roe u t e s is global. Right.
It's just I'm immersing themselves. They immersed in the culture,
like Japanese jazz. Yeah, right.
You just got back from Thailand was last year. Yeah, last year. Yeah.
But now, man, it's, it's a, it's, it's a human thing.
It's a beautiful thing. The momentum of culture.
So strange cause a to Thailand's a great example of that.
It's like there's so different,
there's so in the momentum of culture, like I've just got back from Italy.
There's so different. But yet they're so similar. But there's so that there's,
there's a momentum of the way they live their lives.
It's very unique and unusual.
And I think that's one of the great things about traveling is you get to see,
oh, well, the way we live here is that, especially here in Los Angeles,
which is preposterous. Everybody's, I've never lived there. I grew up,
but I'd never lived in, where do you live now? I live in,
been in Cambridge and they half Cambridge as far as to there,
it's fine until four months of the year when it's just a frozen wasteland.
I just, it's, I used to perform at catch a rising star. Oh yeah,
yeah. In Harvard Square. Absolutely dead off. It's glow. It's Cambridge is,
I mean, it's a great place. It's wonderful.
It's an intellectually that's wonderful things and hang out with the brother
because a lot of gates and yes, Brendan Perry and Bob Dale B.
Boston's a strange place. It really is. There's so many different flavors to it,
you know? But it's um, so god damn cold, but it gets cold.
But that's when it's time to go in the library, read some books.
It also builds character. But that's true too.
There's something about people that grow up in cold climates. Come to terms.
Yeah. Chicago. Yeah. Chicago is a perfect example. Oh yeah.
They're great people there because they have character, absolute Detroit.
They deal with that shit. It got that deal with at times. Yeah.
You're right about that. That
don't mean, I mean, one of the sad or features of our, our moment,
given all our, uh,
the joy of reveling in each other's humanity and music and so forth, is that,
you know, you got impending ecological catastrophe,
escalating nuclear catastrophe,
economic catastrophes to grow test wealth, inequality all around the world,
spiritual catastrophe in terms of intensifying forms of depression,
suicide, wasted lives, lack of self respect,
not believing in oneself and thinking that the only way you can really make it
is by imitating the mainstream forms of conformity.
And then the political catastrophes of right wing movements all around the world
and by right wing movements, what I mean is the rule of big money, big military,
and then scape goat,
the most vulnerable and try to convince the most vulnerable that it's their
fault that they're in the subordinate positions that they are rather than giving
them a fair chance. You see? And that's the makings of,
of new forms of fascism and so on. You see, and you say to yourself,
you know, how do we hold on to some sense of hope?
And there is no hope without wrestling with despair.
If you are afraid of despair, you never have hope. What do you,
when you say wrestle with it,
you got to wrestle at and not allow it to have the last word,
but you got to wrestle with it. When you're talking about the,
your concern about nuclear catastrophe and pending nuclear catastrophe,
yet you talking about what's going on right now with Iran? Well,
I'm thinking about Russia, Russia,
[inaudible] missile heads that ran North Korea stability of war,
US bombing a precious Iran, Iranian brothers and sisters.
I was precious and priceless as anybody else.
It just happened to be under the authoritarian rule that that does need to be
changed and transformed. There's no doubt about it.
But you think you know all the hell they'd been through man eight years when the
United States was on the side of Saddam Hussein. Yeah,
and they were all alone in the world. I mean very much like a Jewish brother,
sisters felt in 1973 they'd already undergone a genocidal attack,
went out, three presses, Jews killed,
and a 73 [inaudible] there in the world.
All by themselves other than u s empire and you say, Oh my God,
who can I rely on? And that brings out the worst in people,
the worst in people because it's all about in crowd,
in group security,
authoritarian on the inside and distrustful of the whole world on the outside.
And this is why it's so difficult to have a discussion about the Israeli
occupation, what are precious Palestinian brothers and sisters,
because to try to be able to cast a light on how an underdog,
because that's the history of Jews 2000 years,
it's basically underdark became an oppressor and how they become top dogs tied
to the u s top dogs. Now you always have again,
those Jewish voices in organization that are critical of Israeli occupation,
critical of any actions of human beings including Jews that are,
that need to be calling the question.
But it's hard to keep track of the rich and prices humanity of Palestinian
brothers and sisters under occupation,
second class citizenship when it's very clear that Jews have been so viciously
treated for 2000 years in the history of history of the West,
as well as the history of the, uh, the Middle East. And yet we have a, a,
a moral duty to keep track of the preciousness of press,
Palestinian babies just as we ought to keep track of depression.
This of Jewish babies and Gaza and Tel Aviv was have, uh,
a spotlight in terms of what those human beings are going through on both sides
of that divide as it were even given the asymmetric relation of power and the
structure of domination. Call the occupation.
But I'd say the same thing about Tibet. I'd say same thing about cashmere.
I'd say same thing about the western Sub-sahara under Moroccan domination.
Uh, there's so many examples that we, human beings, um,
generate that require our, uh,
moral and spiritual witness and our analytical attention and our artists who can
authorize an
even if only for a moment and alternative.
What is the art like in Palestine? The Art, the art,
the art and Palestine. Oh unbelievable.
I mean I would imagine when you're dealing with such an oppressed group of
people that are living in such areas,
situation in time in history is unbelievable.
I was just talking to my dear brother Mark Lamont Hill.
We just had him at Harvard for dialogue on another Palestinian and black
situation and he goes back and forth and he talks about the Palestinian and hip
hop artists. Really? Oh my God,
they got one of the richest subcultures of hip hop. This isn't always the case.
When you have a culture that's down tribes solutely you get the Kurds and
Turkeys to apply the disproportionate amount of influence on Turkish culture.
What's like a good Palestinian hip hop band to look into?
It's a good question cause I, you know, I didn't really follow through with,
I like to listen to that too cause I don't know what they're saying.
I love listening to music where I don't know the language.
You can just feel the spirit coming through in the vibrations. Brazilian nation.
I love Brazilian hip hop because I don't speak Portuguese and it's just amazing.
I've never heard
[inaudible] UFC fighters from Brazil,
they'll come out to their soundtrack is Brazilian artists. Yeah.
Yeah. No, I mean to me, you know,
one of the lifting features of being rooted in the arts and music is that no
matter how ugly and vicious and hateful things are,
it never suffocates the human spirit.
Somebody's going to tell a joke and laugh, somebody's lying and song touches.
So yeah. Know what I mean? Yeah.
And it's almost a way of saying I love you.
Not in a sentimental Hollywood stereotypical way,
but you know that song by Stevie wonder, these three words,
you got that man we can't play or he can't play. All
right cause that was a video that you put up there before. Yeah,
but that video was Mary Johnson singing in a concert.
I definitely know that you did. Yeah,
we made listen to Stevie man cause he's talking about how an aching heart can be
kindled to smile,
open and connect in a world overwhelmed by hatred and distrust that shot.
It's shot through all of us. And we all contribute to it.
We all contribute to it. You see,
I mean that's one of the reasons why even when I talk about, you know,
brought the Trump as a, the gangster,
I call him kind of created a fascist Frankenstein and sees the creation of the
worst of America and the in which
Martin King represents the best. That they are both Americans, Apple Pie.
But any critique of anybody ought to begin with yourself.
Hmm. Let it begin with who we are.
Cause we all got gangsta elements inside of us. No way around us.
[inaudible] human. No, I've never met.
I met him one time I think at the end of Anita Baker concert in the casinos in
the Atlantic city way back in the 80s and it was interesting.
He was there with Mike Tyson I think.
And it was interesting because there was a chocolate affair, you know,
that makes, you don't want vanilla brother there. Right. And you know,
one of the first things that come across to the brother is that he just so glad
to be there hanging out with the brothers. Cool. It's so funny.
You could just tell he just squares, rectangles. You sit,
you go listen to your beach boys, man. Shit, we got James Brown brother,
we got we Brian Wilson, we love you. But we got JB man and,
and but it is and it's a cultural dynamic because he was the Richard's one in
the room though, right? It might touch,
got a lot of money when don king got that everybody too. But uh,
but it was a different kind of dynamic.
And so it's a context in which you embrace, you know,
we embrace him because that's the best of black culture.
We embraced every body. Right. You know what I mean?
Donald Trump's mother shows up from Scotland and 1930 black people been here
nine generation. We're going to say go back where you come from.
Come on in his sister, they bought it as democratic experiment.
We on the other side, the chocolate side of town. But we welcome you.
But don't say nothing about our brown brothers and sisters coming in from
Mexico.
We live because if anybody's definitive about what is America is going to be red
and black people because they are the ones who's undergo the monsters,
crimes against humanity,
the genocide and stolen land on the one hand and these stolen people's and the
human bondage on the other. Those are the pillars,
the worst pillars of the country.
Then you've got democratic visions coming not just from Thomas Jefferson,
but they are coming from the slaves like Frederick Douglas
border crisis is a very interesting one, right? Because it's it, it,
it represents the,
the fear of people from the downtrodden countries where they don't have
opportunity trying to get into this country. Yes,
but then it also represents the fear of, of criminals,
of drug dealers and gangsters and gang members make cartel members making their
way of crossing and victimizing our citizens both days.
Most things are real to human,
but if you tell the lies and make it as if the ladder represents the whole ride,
that's what Trump specializes.
Did you see the video of pence when he was down there at the detention centers
and just, just looking away? No. Humanity. Just very disturbing.
And it's so, it's so sad because here's a brother
who speaks his whole personal identity being a Krish Jess,
and you say not the Mike. I mean, as a Christian,
I'm not trying to call into question your Christian faith and nothing.
I don't have the authority to do that,
but the Bible says in part by the works,
you shall know them, the works of love they exemplify.
You see,
and you know nowadays you've got commodified Christianity and commodified
culture of a declining empire, and you get Christian evangelicals,
91% of sofe pro Trump,
79% sees that he's doing the best possible job. And you say to yourself,
wow,
Christianity seems to have lost meaning of the cross and has become so
accommodated to the empire.
And it was the Roman Empire who put Jesus to death, right?
There's the Roman Empire. You had some Neal colonial elites who cooperate,
but it was a Roman empire who put Jesus to death.
It was the greatest empire of its day, very much like the Persian empire,
the largest greatest empire of its day with Cyrus degree.
Now you've got the Roman empire putting Jesus to death.
And here Jesus is sent there by the crowd,
by the mob, and you say to Beth, Michael Pence,
so you gonna accommodate yourself to Donald Trump.
You're going to accommodate yourself to policies that are so inhumane and bald.
Barrack just to retain your position and try to then rationalize it as a
Christian.
We need some music and some comedy to try to get in contact with his humanity to
change him. But most importantly, you just need a social movement. You know,
you need to get him out of the office. He's accountability,
but with pants or just seeing him in reaction to those people,
it's just a failure of perspective. Cold, dead, Alice.
Well,
the narrative is that they broke the law and that they're imposing upon our
great nation. And you know, this is the, it's crimes of opportunity.
They're just trying to, they're trying to find opportunity. They're trying to,
they're coming over here because they want a better life to not have sympathy
for that.
And, and in other than indigenous peoples and uh,
and my own African peoples,
that is the history to come to the open and bring into the country.
Those who are eager and energy willing to work and sacrifice and the
unbelievable contribution of, uh,
voluntary immigrants to the making of American, not American,
not a nation of immigrants.
I don't like that language because it overlooks indigenous peoples and
involuntary movements like black people and slavery was not America's original
sin.
That's another Neal liberal line that you hear all the time on the corporate
media is if indigenous people suffering has to be rendered invisible, right.
To highlight black people.
What's one of the least discussed injustices of this nation and their current
situation where they're in these reservations with extreme alcoholism,
drug addiction. They still got the rich music and poetry and resistance,
but the, the social conditions are just, but this, they,
they are the casualties of a settler colonial enterprise.
And we rather act as if they don't exist, right? I mean we,
black people became central because our labor and our imagination and culture
became central and we had a ball barrack civil war,
750,000 people dead each life precious. Uh,
and that has been the central event in the shaping of America.
So when people talk about race,
they go straight to blackness as if indigenous people didn't redness,
not integral to,
it's just that they'd been written so invisible and divisions attack has been so
immense.
What's so complicated too that they have their own rules on the reservations.
They're allowed to have gambling and they can have all sorts of,
they have their own sovereignty in a certain way under reservations.
It's very odd. The whole, no, it's true.
And I was blessed to be there in standing rock on a couple of Decembers ago.
It was one of the marvelous moments in my life to stand there with the,
the group there. It was a multiracial group.
People came from all around the world and I am inclined from Canada for the most
part, it was a matter of the indigenous peoples coming together.
Memories of wounded knee, 1890 400 people.
Could you remind people what there with standing rock standing rock was a
struggle over that pipe pipeline. Absolutely.
Trying to put pressure on the Obama administration to ensure that the pipeline
was not built that would violate the sacred a lands and many of the sacred
memories of indigenous peoples.
And it was magnificent because you had to coming together of indigenous nations
because part of the problem, this is true for all little press people,
is fighting among themselves and the difficulty of coming together as the first
time you had the coming together of a significant number of indigenous peoples
nations
unify against the greedy corporate elites who were trying to promote this
pipeline through Canada,
all the way down to the southern section of the United States.
And it was his steps. Well, we first,
we got an announcement right when we were there. It was freezing to me.
It was December and they were hosing people down to, oh Lord Jeff,
they were hosing people down, wet wetting them down while this was all going on.
And it was about minus 15 or whatever it was. It was freezing update,
you know, and uh, uh, but no,
we got an announcement from the Obama administration for a, um,
suspension of it cause they had planned to do it too. I mean, you know,
Obama Administration can be very, uh,
accommodating the Wall Street interests and corporate elite interests and so
forth. Uh, even given the,
the image and spectacle of a black president being a progressive and what have
you, much more progressive than Trump that that's not saying too much. Right.
But, uh, but we got a suspension and uh,
and the struggle continues really, but it was,
it ended as sent tremendous ripples through, uh,
the cultures of indigenous peoples and then nations in terms of coming together
and the fact that it was successful. Absolutely.
And it was Lisa relative victory. Yeah. All these victories are relative,
but very relative victory. It was beautiful just to see again, you know,
you know, you can't down play the role of joy. No brother.
This is so very important. That joy in struggle,
the joy in organizing, the joy in fighting for justice,
the joy in the nightclubs, the joy in the churches at Mazda,
temple's a synagogue.
Joy is something that we need to come back to that one of the great secrets of
the human condition. What are the sources of joy?
What are the conditions for the possibility of joy?
We've been obsessed with pleasure for the last a hundred years or so.
Uh, and there's nothing wrong with, with pleasure,
but pleasure is not the same thing as joy. You know,
when you look at the sparkling eyes of your precious daughter,
that's not pleasure. That's joy. Hmm. You and your wife,
that's deep, deep joy, that sweat and doors.
You could be broke as a 10 commandment financially,
but that memory will bring you joy. That's a real joint, not peacocking death.
Exactly right. That's exactly right. Well,
you said so many amazing things today.
This was one of my favorite podcasts of all time. I just,
I just want to thank you for being here. Is the time up already time?
It's already 11 o'clock.
No, got up my tea,
but man, this has been a blessing though, brothers. My pleasure.
You are what? A human being. You are my brother. You stay strong. Don't be too,
sir. Thank you very much. Is it really 11 man?
[inaudible]
[inaudible].